là on est en plein printemps des poètes
enfin termine notre Printemps des Poètes
commencé le 4 mars on termine le 29 mars
donc c'est un c'est un programme qui est
principal ancré sur la thématique de
cette année du 17e printemp des poètes
c'est-à-dire l'assurrection poétique
d'où la présentation aujourd'hui du du
Baron Perché donc ce ce fameux texte
d'Italo Calvino qui parle vraiment d'
d'un véritable insurgé d'un révolté qui
à 12 ans décide de de grimper dans les
arbres et de de ne plus en r descend de
toute sa vie
com avait 12 ans j'en avais
et puis quelques mois seulement nous
avions été admis à la table de nos
parents
maintenant nous sentions s'accumuler en
nous les griefs
familiaux triste chapitre de l'enfance
voilà on a donc une programmation très
éclectique sur tout le territoire de 550
an en yeline
depuis depuis le début du mois on a
investi le ciné 7 pour un hommage à
prèvert et des Enfants du
Paradis on est allé dans les
médiathèques on a travaillé avec la
ferme de BB on travaille avec la ville
de trappe voilà donc tout toutes ces
chosesl font partie de notre programme
et ce depuis mais existe depuis 13 ans
quoi com regardait le monde du haut de
son
cette maison elle est inscrite sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
mais mais même au-delà puisque nous
travaillons aussi avec le le Conseil
Général pour un festival qui a lieu en
octobre tous les ans depuis 10 ans 11
ans maintenant mais qui nous permet
aussi d'investir les collèges et de
travailler avec des bibliothèques sur
toutes les toutes les communes qui
veulent bien travailler avec nous et
donc nous sommes ouverts nous à toute
collaboration d'autant que cette maison
elle a elle est là vraiment pour pour
les habitants pour les gens euh de
Saint-Quentin mais même au-delà et je
considère moi que la poésie a sa place
partout donc le travail que nous menons
aussi par exemple avec un établissement
comme la Maison de l'environnement des
sciences et du développement durable est
tout à fait cohérent c'estàdire que
intervenir dans une exposition comme
Matis SIM et présenter une rencontre
avec des écrivains pour qui les
mathématiques ont de l'importance comme
les oupiens pour moi c'était tout à fait
logique et naturel voilà donc on a
vraiment mission à être présent partout
parce que je considère moi la poésie a
sa place
partout